the failing is we're looking for Silver
Bullet we're looking for the evaluation
that gets everything and the reality is
there's multiple things we're evaluating
usually what we're evaluating is the
stuff that's easy to measure metrics
right we measure someone's output just
because it's easy to measure and just as
an as side this influenced heavily my my
thinking on the topic the Navy Seals
which are not far from here in carado
within the Navy Seals is's a more Elite
group called SEAL Team Six which many of
us are familiar with and I had the
opportunity to uh spend some time with
the head of training for SEAL Team Six
and I asked him a very simple question
which is how do you choose from the Navy
Seals who gos to be on SEAL Team Six
because they're all
amazing and he drew uh uh a chart uh he
drew a graph XY axis and on the vertical
axis he wrote the word performance and
on the horizontal axis he wrote the word
trust and the way they Define those
terms performance is defined as how good
are you at your job so I think most of
us are familiar with that and trust is
defined what kind of person are you
what's your character right clearly
nobody wants this person the low
performer of low Trust on their team
obviously clearly everybody wants this
person the high performer of high Trust
on their team what they discovered is
that this person over here the high
performer of low trust is a toxic team
member and they would rather have a
medium performer of high trust sometimes
even a low performer of high trust it's
a relative scale over the high performer
of low trust right now if you look at it
in a corporate context we have a million
metrics to measure someone's output to
measure performance and we have
negligible to no metrics to measure
someone's character or trustworthiness
and so what we have is a lot of toxic
team members whose output is so strong
that we end up promoting them into being
toxic leaders right and so it's not that
measuring the performance or the output
is wrong that's totally fine it's that
it's unbalanced we need something to
balance it off so what are we adding to
that